behind the perimeter fence an old Air
Base surrounded by Fields as far as the
eye can see
but it's thought this corner of rural
Essex is about to become home to 1500
Asylum Seekers all of the men
well things have moved really fast over
the past week Tony Clark Holland has
watched as trees have been cut down near
his home and barriers put up the white
Windows you can see the brown ones on
the left there Windows have also been
replaced in unused accommodation blocks
ask the questions and we're just getting
Stonewall we've had no communication so
we're not prepared and it's really about
the impact you'll have on not only the
local community but also the services as
well the doctors dentists police all
those things
the site is currently home to the
ministry of Defense police as well as
Army families who were expected to be
re-housed one of the biggest worries is
what so many men would do with their
days now they could Brave the narrow
country lanes and walk to one of the
local Villages like this one finching
field a couple of miles away then they
could catch a bus for example to the
town of Braintree that's if they had any
money
Braintree District Council says it
strongly believes that the site is
unsuitable adding that the home office
continues to indicate that it hasn't
made a decision yet it's understood the
base would be used for new arrivals but
it's all part of the government's plan
to ultimately move Asylum Seekers out of
around 400 hotels like this one being
used 15 miles from Wethersfield in March
today rather than spending hundreds of
millions of pounds on these sorts of
camps and unsuitable areas
the government needs to be looking at
making sure that people are processed
through the system faster that it can
start to rebuild their lives 130 miles
north the concerns are echoed at Raf
scampson in Lincolnshire the former home
of the Red Arrows before that the famous
Dam Busters
the local Council had only just approved
a deal to develop the 800 Acre Site
earlier this month when talk began of
Asylum Seekers being housed there the
deal that we had on the table less than
24 hours before the government announced
that they might use scampton for this
purpose was great for my area it was
great for local residents it was going
to bring thousands of jobs 300 million
pounds of investment
it's thought that between scampton and
Wethersfield a total of 3 000 people
would be temporarily housed more than
that have already arrived on small boats
this year
the government says the pressure on the
Asylum system is unprecedented and it's
committed to engaging with local
authorities and key stakeholders
but those living close to the old air
bases are clear they feel they're being
kept in the dark
Emma virtually Sky News Essex